comment alors julien clerc après deux en
or du métier te voilà de nouveau parmi
nous gens de médias avec un album qui
s'appelle fais moi une place
alors est ce que tu vas faire maintenant
comme bernard henri lévy fait avec ses
bouts cas c'est à dire les apparitions
médiatiques uniquement quand tu as un
produit à vendre
normalement on fait une apparition visa
de six ans et quelque chose à voir ben
ouais
à moins d'avoir quelque chose qui vous
tirent de votre panier à ce que je t'ai
rencontré à quelques temps dans une
boîte de nuit dix ans et puis je t'ai
dis tiens tu devrais venir dans l'une
est tu m'a dit ah ben non nous on est
programmé les artistes on ne vient que
quand on avait dit ce qu'ils sentent je
viendrai d'ailleurs de vertu et là alors
l'album un bon accueil
jusqu'à présent ce que j'ai lu il ya eu
la phase coeur volcan la phase coeur de
rocker là c'est la phase 3 c'est le bond
en avant qui le ramène ses sources enfin
je veux dire en lit que dès que des
louanges la boucle est bouclée remarque
en ce qui concerne c'est tout à fait
compréhensible et alors tout de suite on
part sur un débat sur les paroliers et
moi je trouve ça un peu dommage les de
dire parce que quoi je pense que c'est
un grand mélodiste et que le problème
c'est qu'à chaque pop abba cette fois-là
il s'est réconcilié avec maurice vallet
enfin chez les homos un nom n'était pas
fâché non tout mais si tu veux on parle
toujours été par oli on nous dit par
l'été mais l'audi signalement ne veut
pas que c'est un peu emmerdant ça non
mais je pense que finalement je pense
qu'on se rend compte avec le temps que
entre tous effectivement tous ces gens
de talent avec qui j'ai travaillé il ya
une unité je croyais que l'unité c'est
moi ouais c'est vrai faut le dire tu
vois avant de parler des paroles i on va
parler de la production aussi parce que
là c'est extrêmement bien produit c'est
phil ramone alors ça s'est passé comment
ta rencontre avec phil ramone pourquoi
tu as choisi phil ramone
je pense que c'est un très grand
producteur ce que je me suis rendu
compte tout de suite que c'est un homme
de chansons qui privilégierait prix dit
la chanson et le chanteur je crois que
c'est ce qu'il a toujours fait dans
toutes ses productions
il a toujours je crois qu'il a su voir
ça que chaque interprète avec qui il
travaillait il a su voir la chose qu'il
fallait mettre en valeur quoique là je
crois savoir qu est ce qui lui a plu
c'est cette voix c'est drôle de voix et
les mélodies - free sans doute way et il
s'est dit et la charge émotionnelle qui
avait dans la voix et ya construit toute
sa production autour de ça c'est la
première personne que je rencontre qui à
ce point où met en valeur au jt récente
est assis aussi
ouais bien pu chanter à six parce que je
crois que il a entendu quand je lui il y
avait quelque chose qui se passait quand
je mets chose mais mes chansons piano un
objet tout seul
un piano et et qu'ils ne retrouvaient
pas tout à fait quand il y avait une
brique d'arrangement il était debout
derrière mon micro peut-être j'étais
trop tendus comme il avait un micro
peut-être me lambert j'ai alors que
quand je me concentre pour jouer j'ai
ils sont elles s'éloignent du
compostelle six mois je suis aussi allé
vite et a remis dans les mêmes
conditions si on va parler des paoli est
quand même surtout qu'elle a un paquet
alors hier françoise hardy sais pas
comment au cours d' habitude je fais
encore d'une musique quand elle m'a dit
m'a dit que ça franchement laid mais pas
du tout oui mais c'est vite avec
français à la première fois sur l'album
d'avant et mais c'est ce qui fait sa
qualité et c'est que si personne qui dit
toujours la vérité
on peut le prendre plus ou moins bien
moi je préfère qu'on me dise la vérité
qu'autre chose
la liga l'aimé pas oui mais c'était un
peu plus amusant c'est encore sur
l'album d'avant où elle m'avait de on
lui ai fait écouter la musique d'une
chanson qui est devenu par la suite pour
qui tu te prends et où elle a dit je
l'avais co composé avec un copain
anglais elle a dit vous êtes mis à deux
pour faire ça elle a écrit les paroles
devant l'as pareil je vais présenter une
musique elle n'est pas du tout bon bah
la grèce on veut dire mais dire
franchement j'aime pas à la fin et on
m'a dit t'as rien d'autre moi je suis
ici j'ai autre chose mais bon je suis
pas sûr que ça soit fini
quand tu composes des musiques tu sais
qui tu vas les portes closes et j'avais
été un peu faux jeton et j'avais cité de
la musique à david et david heyman elle
fait quelque chose et on était convenu
et lui est moins bon que ça n'allait pas
vraiment réagi si tu n'en veux pas je
vais la montrer
françois je crois que on a fait quelque
chose on s'accroche un peu on ne sait
pas là on lui la rater finalement c'est
ce2 qui avait raison quand on n'a pas
autre chose
et là c'est là que je vais présenter
cette musique est devenue fais moi une
place est bonne mais alors il ya david
montant vieux temps vieux complice david
mc neil il ya thierry séchan il fait
partie du club des patineurs
ouais hein un fan ouais il m'a envoyé un
texte et j'ai trouvé dans ce texte avait
des choses que j'avais déjà dit dans les
chansons auparavant bon une chanson en
particulier de la période
les tiennent au moose alors le soir et
avait une grande fête
vers son frère et j'étais un petit peu
génieau emmerder alors mes radio m'a dit
tu as vu comme on passe comment puisque
ces bosses comment fin et il a même
ajouté je pensais pas qu'on fera quelque
chose de super comme ça 8 c'est vrai que
c'est beau mais renault m'a coupé à part
une vidéo c'est vrai il ya des trucs
dedans on a l'impression que tu as déjà
fait ça alors je les trouvais thierry
julier coaching je pense pas dû faire
cette chanson pour cette raison mais
comme le texte qui est me plaît bien je
vais essayer de mettre une musique qu'on
essaiera de la place sassine terme
horrible center bbc radio place quelque
2 et du coup en la faisant je me suis
blessé prendre la chanson je pouvais
bien un trou j'ai dit vont aller alors
jean louis murat c'est la première fois
cette voie là car allemand ce que c'est
vrai ce sont deux maisons de disques aux
exploits on sait elle a rencontré je
parle aussi rencontrer le temps d'un
dîner très rapide en plus qui était très
tard vous et mona on a parlé de jeu pour
conserver bien oui enfin je pense que
c'est bien je crois je pense que il ya
le début la d'une collaboration qui peut
qui peut c'est moche et on est
suffisamment différent que ce soit
intéressant
en plus je pense que jean louis il a un
côté comme ça provocateur
que j'aime bien même voilà donc on a
parlé de tout pendant ce repas de foot
tous ah bon et puis j'ai envie aux bains
je crois que il a pas tellement aimé
parce que c'est pas besoin d'endroits
qui l'aiment vraiment ferrand l'airé
ouais non mais même à clairement je ne
sais pas si mon nom
et puis donc vent il sait ben ali c'est
qu'il est resté le temps d'être polypill
ces cas c'est bon et au moment où il
partait je les écoute si ça tu te dis de
loyer un thème cher à notre musique de
sujets ensuite de textes dans les quinze
jours une
or jean claude vannier qui est connu
pour les orchestrations qu'il a fait
pour les chansons qui s'est fait lui
même et on l'avait vu au trottoir de
buenos aires et là il a fait beaucoup de
chansons sur le lis quand même non 5
ouais c'est bien c'est bon sous ce nom
c'est pas je crois pas que ces questions
chouchou c'est que il ya une espèce de
d'excitation ça se passait tellement
bien que je les écoute comme ça continue
en voyant je joue quand nous allons du
thé j'avais donc effectivement trottoirs
buenos aires juifs russes
moi je suis grand fan de lui depuis
longtemps je me souviens avoir fait
découvrir
jean-claude vanille à diane dufresne ya
bien longtemps bon donc je suis fan de
ce qu'il écrit en tant qu'auteur
compositeur et là je me suis dit on va
essayer ça l'intéresse de faire
travailler comme auteur donc plus
marrant qui avait travaillé à longtemps
sur un album comme arrangeur l'album sur
les terres de france austal usa que là
ils reviennent comme auteur on a écrit
pratiquement portée des vieilles amours
il valait alors c'est la première fois
que vous retravailler ensemble depuis
quand même temps son retour de momo
ouais ça tafiré renault arlette alors ça
a été ouais c'était vachement content
surtout qui me ramène quelque chose mais
il est revenu avec plein est revenu avec
cinq ans j'en ai appris qu parce que
j'étais assez avancé à ce moment là en
écriture l'album et puis j'ai vraiment
pris ce qui me plaisait le plus comme ça
chassons je voulais sur l'album ce soit
rasé et crée mais si on peut dire hiro
danon
etienne parce que nous on se croise oui
on se croise souvent d'abord etienne a
fait savoir qu'ils avaient bien cet
album je suis content des cordes en fa
enfin un album qui est bien en plus csu
copains sincèrement ça bon là je
plaisante un peu mais je suis content
sincèrement donc des fois on se voit
comme ça t'en entendre on est contents
de se revoir
je ne sais pas si le moment est venu où
si jamie reviendra pour être sûr je ne
peux pas dire aujourd'hui on a lu un
jour il dit oui un joli nom voilà ça
sera d'ailleurs même il a même été
question corps écrivent à vrai dire ce
disque de johnny pour ne rien cacher g
j'attends le texte s'il l'a pas envoyé
c'est que vont peut-être se parle m
peut-être pas mais déjà suis déjà
content que tout ces diagrammes iode se
termine comme ça et que parce que je
pense que tout s'est tu es tellement
passionnel qui est normal que choisir ça
c'est comme les gens qui s'aiment un
acquis qui les gens qui ont vécu
ensemble qui vivent plus ensemble et
garde toujours un droit sur l'autre
c'est normal et en même temps c'est
assez tous avancer c'est compliqué là
tout d'un coup ça devient plus cool et
vont évidemment que ça me fait mal au
rang terriblement plaisir